think that thin privilege is a real
thing go around no it's not a real thing
all the things she listed is thin
privilege
they're just things that come with the
fact that
you're thin it's not necessarily
privileged if you're fat of course you
know there's certain health
complications are going to come so of
course doctors are going to blame
everything on that your bmi is going to
be over 30. so
that's not a thing that you don't get
because you're you've got thin privilege
it's just the fact
is is there an echo there's the comments
or saying there's an echo i think
there's an echo on the
oh on the video okay okay that's fine
then
um
what do you think
yeah i don't i want to say there's
anything such as uh thin privilege but
there are as you said the
ways people address you speak to you
when you're
when you look maybe extremely different
like when you have a certain size on an
airplane you know like she was saying
um but yeah it's it's not necessarily a
privilege it's just i think society's
letting you know
um
when you're too big you know
that's not the way to go i just think
that's what it is okay um i disagree i
do think there is such a thing as thin
privilege because it's not just about
the extremes of being particularly large
you can be still like a relatively
healthy weight but
like slightly bigger and you will
definitely be treated differently like
i i know of people who are maybe like a
size 14 16
and
a friend of mine like returned an item
and the person who was serving her said
well i think this might not have been
your size like you're bigger than that
was she squeezing no she just was
returning it because she didn't like the
item
and and to say it was a poor fit that
doesn't necessarily mean that you don't
fit into that size but as i'm sure we've
probably all experienced
everywhere that you shop and every
garment that you buy
is a is a completely different size like
every retailer works to a different um
that's true sizing profile
so
that is an example to me of of thin
privilege but if i go to the shop and i
buy a shirt and my friends tell me oh
that looks too small on you you should
have gone a different size
like what what does that mean it doesn't
mean that you know no that's different
but it just means that people are saying
it doesn't it doesn't fit you or [ __ ] it
might not fit
in this particular circumstance that was
a sales advisor saying that to somebody
who's returning an item that's different
to trying something on and your friends
saying oh that's a bit tight on you
but just just advice isn't it like that
might be too small for you she's just
trying to help help out yeah is there a
job i've been a sales assistant you know
you kind of have to tell people does
this fit you does this look good on you
so
fair enough she was returning it and as
a sales person she was probably trying
to convince her to get a different size
oh maybe you might like it then i don't
think it's anything to do with oh that's
fat phobia because
it's just it could just be a fact that
it might look better on you if you try a
different size
because when i hear the word privilege i
think of something that like you're born
with
but but yeah like it's inherent yeah
like like because one one thing that i
often hear is white privilege right and
so that's something that's something
you're born with
right but but fat privilege or a fat or
thin privilege is a choice
thin privilege isn't a thing if i'm if i
that's my opinion i don't think it's a
thing i think we need to look at the
root
you know definition of the word
privilege when i think of privilege i
think
something
or um a treatment you are afforded
um because of a specific attribute that
you possess so i don't necessarily
believe it has to be something that
you're
um born with i think just the context is
we began to use the word privilege like
white privilege and thin privilege and
things like that
it gives the impression that it's
something that you're born with and
can't change but we have to look at the
root definition of privilege and i think
that's what it is things that you're
afforded because of a certain
characteristic or maybe not even a
characteristic a factor that you possess
whether subconsciously or consciously
thin privilege is not a thing i don't
think it's a thing i don't think it's
anything oh i think especially going
back to that tick tock a lot of the
things that she said that she doesn't
experience because of the nature of the
body shape that she has are just
standard things
are just standard things i don't think
think privilege is a thing i think if we
look at the other end of the extreme
you know like
bigger people that's when we can start
maybe using some of those words but
well i don't think thankful is the thing
um i'm borderline thin in certain
say cultures or beauty standards and i
don't think it affords me
anything more in my
daily life i don't think
so pretty privilege is a yeah that's
what i was going to say i would say
pretty privilege is the thing i mean
yeah even the comments they're they're
talking about you
listen
i think privilege
how i would define privilege is an
unearned advantage for preferable
treatment
so like
so white privilege yeah you're born with
that so it's kind of like
the
the preference the preferable treatment
you get
is an unearned advantage because you
haven't worked for that preferable
treatment right
but thin privilege if you're slim
that's
you've earned that
so it's not it's not privileged
um
because
you you ate less than other women maybe
attention attained is the right word i
was gonna say i do disagree with your
definition of privilege just because you
know if you're rich there's certain
preferential treatment you get from
people but you worked hard to become
rich yes and so that thing is rich
privilege though i think there is yes
there's certain things afforded to you
because you are rich
people treat you differently because you
are rich that's true so the biggest
privilege is
would you say somebody is more
privileged if they started from nothing
and became rich or somebody inherited
that richness i don't think there's any
because i could be born poor and then
become a billionaire i'll be very
privileged so i don't think it has
anything to do with that i would say i'd
change my stance there might be such a
thing as thing privilege but i don't
think it's a bad thing can i ask what
made you change your stance because i'm
thinking about it you know based on the
def initially i was thinking of
definition privilege as something that
you
character that you're characterized as
inherently and it gives you an advantage
in life
but then now i'm thinking of you know
you can work hard and become rich and
become privileged because of it so i
don't think it's necessarily something
that's inherent to you
when i hear privilege i just think of
something you're like born like when i
hear rich privilege i don't think of
someone that was broke and became rich i
think of someone that was born rich yeah
what you're saying i get that but i
think it does
being rich does give you a certain
privilege but no matter how hard you
worked for it but when you say privilege
like i think of something you didn't
earn yeah what's the what's the
difference between gaining privilege
because you got to a certain position
and then gain in the perks that come
with that position
so can you could you rephrase that so
what's what's the difference
right so like for example like if you
say for example oh
um you you become the
i don't know let's say you become a
pilot right which means that part of
your privilege as a pilot is you don't
have to go through security when you
travel
right okay is that a privilege or is
that a perk that you gained from getting
a position oh i see the difference
because if you come here
you can kind of say that being fat
is a privilege now because of as a fat
person you get a privilege of calling
people pharmaphobic
for privilege i think it is called
people
for not wanting to date yeah but yeah
yeah and you get to
one at a time guys glorified questions
i